in wien bin ich verbunden mit armin wolf
er ist tv journalist in österreich
arbeitet für das orf die wichtigste
nachrichtensendung im österreichischen
fernsehen zib 2 moderator seit zwölf
jahren und er sonst jetzt zugeschaltet
schönen guten tag nach der wahl sagen
hallo wir haben gerade im beitrag
sozusagen ihren fall gesehen es hat im
nachgang eines durchaus kontroversen
interviews äußerungen gegeben aus der
politik zum beispiel von einem
verwaltungsrat eben orf der in einer
auszeit nahegelegt hat die ist denn
jetzt der aktuelle stand die situation
der aktuelle stand ist nicht wesentlich
anders als vor ein paar wochen oder vor
ein paar monaten ich bin nach wie vor
moderator der sendung die ich schon sehr
lange moderiere ich bin nach wie vor
stellvertretender chefredakteur und dfb
ist nach wie vor sehr böse auf den orf
an dem hat sich nichts geändert das war
auch schon vorbei monaten so es gab eine
letzte woche quasi noch mal so eine
kleine eskalation
das interview das sie gemacht haben war
ja nun wirklich keine umarmung würden
sie jetzt etwas aus der rückschau anders
machen
ich würde bei jedem interview das ich
gemacht habe wenn ich es nochmal machen
könnte etwas anders machen auch bei
diesem interview er würde ich vielleicht
20 25 prozent anders machen hätte ich
die chance dass ich nicht anders machen
würde wäre aber genau jene passage um
die kontroverse jetzt geht nämlich den
vergleich der bildsprache eines f b
jugend plakats und der ns-propaganda das
glaube ich ist ein vergleich gewesen
dass ich jedem historisch sensiblen
menschen aufdrängt und ich habe keine
leitartikel geschrieben oder keinen
kommentar gesprochen in dem ich gesagt
habe die fpö verhält sich wie die nsdap
das wäre ja auch absurd sondern ich habe
diese beiden bilder her gezeigt und den
generalsekretär der fpö gefragt ob er
mir den unterschied erklären kann und er
konnte live im fernsehen vor sehr sehr
vielen zusehern darauf antworten was
immer er wollte und er hat ja auch
darauf geantwortet was immer er wollte
er sehr sehr emotional geworden
bis sie ihn zu einer droh
nun ist durchaus herr vilimsky ja auch
ein profi ja sehr konnte wissen dass
wenn man ein interview mit ihnen geht es
durchaus hart zur sache gehen kann
was sozusagen die nach denen das
eigentlich ins gespräch es angeht da
wird es dann spannend für uns aus der
außenperspektive jetzt in dem falle aus
der nachbar perspektive es hat zu einer
gehörigen missstimmung in der vp fdp
koalition geführt
es hat aber jetzt auch zu einer
positionierung von kanzler kurz pro
pressefreiheit geführt aber dennoch wie
beschädigt ist der orf und das
mediensystem in österreich insgesamt aus
ihrer sicht das ist eine eine große
frage
die fpö hat seit sehr langer zeit ein
großes problem mit dem orf sie hat ein
sehr großes problem mit qualitätsmedien
überhaupt wie populistische parteien auf
der ganzen welt da gibt es ein
grundkonflikt der da lautet das seriöser
journalismus differenziert sich mit
argumenten an die diskurs fähigkeit
seines publikums wendet während
populistische politik eben qua
definition auf vereinfachung setzt um
sich eher an die emotionen und auch an
die ressentiments ihre wähler wende
deswegen berichten qualitätsmedien auf
der ganzen welt kritisch über
populistische politik zum einen zum
zweiten sehen populistische bewegungen
traditionellen medien als teil des
systems und als teil der elite die sie
ja bekämpfen wollen
das ist mir das grundsätzlich das gibt
es in vielen ländern auf der welt und
was in österreich noch dazukommt ist
dass die fpö das gefühl hat dass sie es
hier das hier zur regierungspartei auf
private medien natürlich alle die wenig
einfluss nehmen kann aber möglicherweise
auf den öffentlich rechtlichen rundfunk
in dem sie gemeinsam mit der vp ein
neues orf gesetz macht und das kann
durchaus für den orf bedrohlich werden
lassen sie uns wir haben jetzt viel über
elektronische medien gesprochen noch ein
bisschen auf den print weiten auf die
zeitungslandschaft wie diverse ist sie
eigentlich noch wir hören dass sie im
grunde genommen maßgeblich von einem
jungen unternehmer ihres landes auch ein
bisschen im hintergrund beherrscht wird
was in österreich sehr untypisch ist und
anders als in den allermeisten anderen
europäischen ländern außer vielleicht in
england ist das boulevard medien extrem
stark
sie müssen sich mal vorstellen die
kronen zeitung das größte medien des
landes ein boulevard-blatt ist relativ
gesehen zur bevölkerung etwa dreimal so
stark wie die bild zeitung in
deutschland dazu kommen aber noch zwei
andere sehr sehr große
boulevardzeitungen alle drei
unterstützen tendenziell die regierung
dazu gibt es dann noch ein paar
qualitätszeitungen die eher kritisch
berichten was man jetzt sieht und das
ist tatsächlich neues dass die regierung
versucht kritische zeitungen durch den
entzug von öffentlichen inseraten zu
bestrafen
das gab es so jedenfalls in diesem
ausmaß noch nicht dazu kommt dass die
fpö ein ganz eigenes kleines medien
imperium aufgebaut hat eben weil sie
sich von den traditionellen medien
benachteiligt gefühlt hat seit vielen
jahren sind sie sehr sehr früh in
sozialen medien und online medien
gegangen
die facebook-seite von herrn strache des
parteichefs hat 800 1000 fans in einem
land mit neun millionen einwohnern das
ist umgerechnet auf deutschland hätte
der acht millionen facebook-fans und es
gibt dazu auch satelliten medien im
umfeld der fpö die online durchaus sehr
präsent sind und die werden nun von
spd-geführten ministerien mit
öffentlichen inseraten gefüttert und
finanziert während gleichzeitig
unabhängige kritische zeitungen durch
inseraten entzug bestraft werden das ist
nur ein letzter knackpunkt wenn sie
gestatten sie sind seit über 20 jahren
im geschäft beobachten sozusagen die
medien österreichs sehr sehr intensiv
und erfahren sie ich glaube anfänge
damals im landesstudio des orf in tirol
was hat sich wenn sie es auf einen punkt
bringen müssten seit ihren anfängen
verändert was sich definitiv verändert
hat ist dass die professionelle
kommunikation von politik sehr sehr viel
weiter professionalisiert wurde also
allein das innenministerium hat 51
mitarbeiter in seiner
kommunikationsabteilung die größte
innenpolitische redaktion ist österreich
etwa 15 akteure und wir reden über ein
ministerium dass das was mehr als
dreimal so viele mitarbeiter in ihrem pr
beckert hat das heißt die politik müsste
zunehmend kreativ auf während
rezeptionen leider aufgrund die
ökonomischen krise
nehmen wir weiter abrüsten müssen daher
halte ich für den größten trend es ist
europa in allen teilen europas und
richtig sehen wir eine bedenkliche
einschränkung von medienfreiheit also
dass sich die türkei so entwickelt wie
sie sich entwickelt hat brot und ungarn
aber das hätten wir vor 10 15 jahren
oder so nicht erwartet grifka für dieses
gespräch gehen nach wien armin wolfs sie
weiter dranbleiben
vielen dank für das gespräch
schönen tag danke